foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth we help you do work
that you love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host today Jade
warshaw and I am joined by possibly my
favorite
the incomparable George Campbell wow you
hear that Dr John Maloney Ken Coleman
are you listening somewhere Ken Coleman
is seething I'm just kidding but we're
here to take your calls about your life
your money give us a call man the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five and let's go straight through
the phone lines we got Amber and
Chattanooga Tennessee what's going on
Amber
um so so I am starting to try to do the
baby step
and I am having trouble getting started
with the first one
um every time I have money put up
something comes out to where I have to
use that money because I don't have a
choice
so the first baby step for those of you
listening is baby step one getting a
thousand dollars saved and so Amber
you're having a hard time with that
because you keep falling back
and spending it am I right
and correct are you using a budget right
now
I am I write down everything that I owe
for each paycheck
um I go you know like if something's
done from the first of the month to say
the 19th because I get paid every two
weeks all right what is old in between
those days that way not everything's
come now one check
um but it seems like you know I try to
calculate you know my tabbings and stuff
for church plus I want to put money back
and it's like I can't get either one of
those started right so when you are
having to go into your emergency fund
what are the type of purchases that are
causing you to do that are they
unexpected charges or is it just
month-to-month stuff that you're like
man I forgot to budget for that and now
here we are
um so
I'm slow starting to get ahead this last
month
and
my dog ended up started having seizures
so I had to go take him to the vet which
was very very unexpected and of course I
had already
paid all my bills for that week and that
was the only money I had left to be able
to take him to the vet to have him
checked out
um
so can I ask you like what's your income
Ben like what how much money are you
bringing in
um so I've been working overtime at work
so mine has two paychecks have been over
1900 every two weeks okay so you're
making almost four thousand dollars a
month you know correct here's the thing
for folks listening when it comes to
emergencies the way that we think
through whether something is an
emergency where you would dip into that
money is it's got to be totally
unexpected it's got to be something
that's totally necessary and it's got to
be urgent right George and you know so
the dog was one example is there another
example that you can give because I
don't want to come at you hard Amber uh
with the dog stuff just yet so I want to
know is there another example
so
so the house we're living in we just
moved in this past July we're trying to
buy this house so we're leasing it on
this house
uh me and my husband and my
mother-in-law my mother-in-law lives
with us okay so she helped as far as the
house experience where is his income
going
uh towards the house
so y'all split bills
um we do split bills but he's on
disability
so he doesn't get much a month so his
whole check goes towards the house uh we
agreed to do that that way we could put
that up for the whole month and then I
take care of the rest of the bills
I think that this is this sounds to me
like a budgeting issue I think that you
guys need to combine your money together
so if he's making you're making 4 000 a
month what if his is how much is his
his is a little over 1300 a month okay
so combine that income and do a budget
together that's I know that you're
saying that hey all his money goes
towards it but having it all in one
place on purpose and then you know
you're just gonna have to draw some
lines in the sand and say all right we
got to get this money saved most people
are able to get a thousand dollars saved
in 30 days and so for you you might have
to go all out to get this money put
aside because if you're just kind of
like going little by little yeah a
little ankle ankle biter stuff can pop
up but if you're like I'm gonna sell
stuff I'm I'm gonna pick up an extra job
I'm gonna do whatever it takes to get
this thousand dollars saved so that the
big bad wolf is no longer you know
breathing at the door you're gonna have
to do that and then you're gonna have to
make sure that this budget is airtight
it sounds like your budget is not as
detailed as it needs to be and there's
some money leaks happening yeah and
there needs to be a line item for Fido
you know what I'm saying you gotta make
sure Rover has got some money that
you're putting aside a little bit every
month and like a little sinking fund so
that when those vet bills pop up because
because they will you've got some money
to pull from at least that's what I
would do George yeah what are you using
right now to budget Amber
um so I've just been using a notebook
that I write everything down I wrote
everything down that I owe every month
uh how much I pay each month plus I also
wrote down how much I owe as far as that
day let's go good well I'll do one
better and here's what I want y'all to
do as a couple this is not an Amber
thing and then he does his thing and
covers his bill sit down together I'm
gonna gift you one year of every dollar
premium inside of every dollar premium
you're gonna list out your income your
expenses your debt just like that
notebook but there's another
feature on there called paycheck
planning and this will allow you to see
where the bills fall when the money's
going to come out because right now it
feels overwhelming because you're trying
to keep track of that let the robots do
the work for you so you can focus on
getting uh getting out of this situation
that means we're selling stuff because
right now I'm seeing a whole bunch of
margin even after the mortgage is paid
you got 3 800 bucks left over and it's
disappearing into the abyss
right because of these little ankle
biters and probably some lifestyle
spending are y'all eating out
I try to make everything at home good
are you guys investing at all
uh no okay good are you getting a tax
refund
get that tax refund and up paid off one
of our loans that we was paying on and
that pretty much took all our tax
refunds remember baby steps thousand
bucks goes first
so we did we have that with part of the
refund
uh we did okay so I think once you have
that thousand bucks as your foundation
our goal is to never touch that if
there's another emergency let's see if
we can cash flow it with future expense
with future income with selling stuff
you're working overtime can he pitch in
at all
is he on board with this plan or is it
just Amber right now
and pretty much it's just me right now I
think that's part of the problem I do
too and it's going to cause resentment
down the road when you're busting your
butt and he's like I don't know what
you're working so hard for let's go out
to eat tonight you're like I'm trying to
do this budget thing man I'm trying to
get out of get us out of debt yeah and
that's where you guys need to be
budgeting together and him being on
disability really doesn't have anything
to do with you know I kind of felt like
she said that as a well he's on
disability he has this money his money
just goes towards that as though it's
not as big a part of it but it is if
you're listening and you're a couple
you've got to combine your finances
otherwise you're just you know it makes
it so much more difficult because I can
tell in the way her voice she feels like
she's having to shoulder all of this and
well you're living like roommates
eventually you're going to get that
roommate resentment yeah that's true and
so you gotta act like married people you
can share a bed you can share DNA you
can share a bank account I promise
that's right when you say I do it's not
just I do to the the easy stuff it's
it's I do to the challenges and money
can be a challenge until you really
start understanding what you need to do
until you get on same page but man it's
worth it so true well hang on the line
Amber Austin's gonna pick up we're gonna
get you every dollar premium to help you
get on track and get it from notebook
into the app where you guys can share
this together I love it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host today Jade warshaw joined by
George Campbell fellow Ramsay
personality and uh George you know all
the time we get folks sending us things
and our DMS are like hey you got to see
this whether it's money related whether
it's just something outrageous and you
came across something here recently yes
I I usually when 10 people send me
something within like six hours I'm like
we got to talk about this apparently
it's trending I got to keep up with the
times and so thank you to all of you who
follow us over at Jade warshaw on
Instagram George Campbell with a K on
Instagram and usually people send me
videos just to like rile me up yeah but
this one I thought was going to be a
ryler upper and it was actually a funny
parody video but it perfectly sums up
what people are seeing out there when it
comes to financial advice on the
internet so I wanted to play it for you
and get your reaction live okay I
haven't seen
so let's let's let's play it James
the next time you're gonna order
ubereats don't use that twenty dollars
to buy a Mercedes G-Wagon why because
you can write it off as a business
expense for the LLC that you registered
earlier in the morning now you gotta
drive that G wagon for 24 hours for
ubereats delivering food
and then you're going to use that money
that you just made to get an FHA loan
that you can get a rental property with
once you get the rental property you're
going to rent out all the four units
you're going to sleep in the bathroom
this way you don't have to pay rent and
you're going to use what's called
monthly recurring Revenue that's passive
income
what you're going to do with that
passive income is buy my course
oh my gosh so Finance gurus be like is
that how we sound no that's not what we
sound like it's what the opposite side
those people those gurus yes so let me
just recap the what this guy mentioned
and it's lit he just riddled off all of
the get rich quick basically that you
guys hear on on Tick Tock and Instagram
so he starts off talking about the
Mercedes G Wagon yes use that to drive
with your LLC so make an LLC once you
get the G wagon it's a tax write-off you
hear those all the time it's always then
you drive for Uber Eats use that money
to get nothing down FHA loan which you
can use to buy a rental property then
you house hack by having everyone else
live in there you live in the bathroom
rent free and that's monthly recurring
Revenue mrr as we call it in the biz
that's passive income baby and then you
use that to buy the guy's course and
that perfectly sums up how I feel about
all these Financial Guru idiots out
there pitching their schemes yeah that's
you know what that's the thing if you if
if you watch one of these Instagram or
Tick Tock videos and you don't get it
instantly like to me that's a red flag
like Finance it's not mystical it's not
like this thing that you've got to be
like super smart to understand this
stuff should be simple like managing
your finances the concepts are actually
very very simple so when I hear
something like that I'm like what why
would you do that like just just be
smarter like be smarter than that here's
my general Mantra with financial advice
on the internet if it sounds sexy run
away if it sounds like work it's
probably the right thing to do you're on
the right path if it looks like hard
work and it makes me go oh gosh you're
right yeah if it convicts you if it gets
you excited that's a sign that you need
to run that's a red flag all right first
step to wealth baby get your Mercedes G
Wagon I'm like hey all right I'm picking
up what he's putting down what's next
yeah get a rental property okay that
sounds slick yeah I'm making passive
income now Jade it's so passive you
don't have to do anything when I hear
the words pass it look when I hear the
word passive income in Quad Plex I I'm
done I feel like I've heard the word
quad Plex far too many times I'm
perplexed by all the plexes y'all are
throwing out there oh my God this is
spot on and so here's the thing the best
way to build wealth is by doing none of
those things and it's a lot of work it's
just getting out of debt staying out of
debt investing for the future and things
that have proven track records and then
just sleeping at night and going to a
job you love how's that for the American
dream not using your G wagon as a tax
write-off to form the LLC and then you
borrow from your own self tax free Jade
because debt isn't taxable that's why
you gotta leverage debt right that's
what they all tell you
it's just at the end of the day it's get
rich quick And We Don't Preach any of
that we we understand and we know that
it's a process we know that when you uh
make the decision to handle your money
well when you put when you put good
habits to use it takes time Building
Wealth takes time I mean look at your
story you you started out with what
Thirty forty thousand dollars 40 Grand
in debt paid it off but you were able
over the course of how many years 10
years 10 years to turn a negative net
worth into a million dollar net worth
and it's none of the things that I know
that was a parody but it's none of the
things that that guy was preaching well
what they preach is get rich fast get
out of debt slow hang on to it as long
as possible we're preaching get out of
that fast get rich slow it's so
counter-cultural that it's now become
controversial yeah it requires a
paradigm shift in your mind 100 because
what we teach it is not out there in
culture when I go on Instagram and in
the tick tocks there everything is you
got to start investing now time is money
and I'm like well wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute is this really the
best uh is this the best path that's
going to get me there the I want to say
the fastest but you know there's so much
more to it it's not just going fast and
and
wealth gained hastily will dwindle
that's what I'm thinking about in my
mind right now Proverbs 13 11 wealth
gained hastily will dwindle but whoever
gathers little by little will increase
it that's Timeless Timeless my man
Solomon was doing Twitter before it was
cool okay I know that's speaking in
tweets all right let's take a call let's
talk to Mike he's in Columbus Ohio
what's going on Mike
thanks so much for taking my call uh my
question is around uh buying a car so my
wife and I we're on baby steps four five
and six we don't have any debt except
our mortgage we owe about 200 on our
mortgage and I really want a new car the
car is going to cost me about 40K and I
wanted to get it next year but I'm
conflicted I keep going back and forth
because it's like I can't justify paying
that much for a car when I still have a
mortgage so my question is should I pay
the mortgage off and then quickly ramp
up the savings and get a new car or
should I just go ahead and get the car
what's your household income
um about 270 plus incentive can be up to
about 30k way to go that's very nice so
how quickly could we pay off this house
making 270 with no debt
so we did
um analysis
um we did like three years we can do it
in like three years
I believe that and I bet you could beat
it
so here's the question can you wait two
years to get this car three years to get
this car
I think I can the car I'm driving now is
a beater
um it's about 10 years old but it's
still running very very well
um but I'm just I keep getting
embarrassed driving it honestly um who
are you trying to impress Mike you make
300 000 you have any debt I mean let me
ask this do you have to go straight to
the Forty thousand dollar car can you
upgrade what you have now slightly in
cash flow that and then save the big you
know the big gift for after the mortgage
is paid yes I thought about that as well
but then it's like if I want to get a
car I want to get something I really
want so I might as well just wait and
just wait it out you know so it's either
wait it out or just get the car here's
the thing Mike I mean I've had the car
for eight years so it's like I can wait
three more at this yeah you're not
violating any of the Ramsay principles
we're not mad at you it's okay if you
get the car I'll tell you what I did I
dangled that Mortgage in front of me
until that was paid off to upgrade my
little beater Honda Civic and when I did
it it went from this I deserve mentality
to I earned that let's celebrate and so
that's just how I'm wired I'm wired why
I need a goal in front of me otherwise I
get a little lazy I get a lackadaisical
and so there's nothing wrong if you save
up and pay cash for a 40 000 car making
270. there really isn't
so if you if you're in for it go for it
but don't regret it either and go man I
hate myself now for doing that I could
have paid down the more it's fine when
you move from baby step three to four
it's from intense to intentional and
some people go harder at the mortgage
like I did some people go all right it's
going to get paid off within two years
anyways so let's upgrade the car and the
rule of thumb there with when it comes
to Vehicles things with a motor in it
you don't want it to be any more than 50
of your annual income things with the
motor because we know they go down in
value so with his case I mean he's got
270 000 in income which is amazing so
buying a forty thousand dollar car I
mean I don't know what his other cars
are worth but I'm sure I'm sure he's
within a reason 50 limit that's funny
you got you know it's funny you guys are
definitely Cut From the Same Cloth
because I if it were Jade I'd be like
I'm just gonna you know upgrade slightly
if you're sick of driving a beater and
then I'd probably go all in but I'm in
but it's kind of like baby step one I
kind of like the fire under me of hating
this beater so much that it drives me to
pay off the mortgage faster you get a
mid-tier car that you're like this is
nice then you start going huh
everything's fine but it also matters
how long it took you to pay off the debt
like it matters how long you were in the
process before because some folks by the
time they pay off their debt they're
like I need like something I need to
feel like I'm rewarded here people call
in and they're broke and they're like
I'm about to buy a 60 000 Dollar Car
Mike's over here making 300 with no debt
going hey can I buy a 40 000 car I love
it yet again it boils down to when you
do this stuff guys you have options you
get to ask fun questions like that can I
bit buy a 40 000 car dollar card now or
can I buy it later this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsay show I am
your host Ramsay personality Jade
warshaw joined by George Campbell and uh
George during the break we had some
Lively discussion about honestly just
the state of personal finance right now
um all you have to do is turn on the
news for a second to hear inflation
all-time high mortgage rates you know
folks are going crazy and and it's just
here's the thing
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on with the economy there's a lot
going on with the government
um and you kind of just have to
choose
how it's going to affect you and we did
we did a segment a while back and we
called it The Perfect Storm of stupid
and I like that and I think it's time to
talk about it again George because we're
seeing this and uh the stats have come
out a record 69 of the public at this
time holds a negative view about the
economy so ask yourself whether you're
driving in your car right now you're
watching on YouTube is that you do you
have a negative view of the economy
right now the stats tell us you probably
do both now because of headlines exactly
um and only 24 here's we're just going
to go through this and tell you guys 24
are saying they don't feel like now is a
good time to invest in stocks oh they're
saying now is a good time now is a good
time 76 say it's not a good time yeah
they're wrong
they're wrong three out of four people
are saying don't invest right now it's a
bad time to invest which is really just
the opposite because I'm like no when
the when the market is down that's when
you want it it's on sale sale that's the
kind of sale I want to fall for yeah and
you know there's just so many things
going on uh it says many people aren't
cutting their expenses and they're
keeping their lifestyle the same even
though like I said you can throw a rock
and hit somebody who's gonna complain
about inflation you know you can throw a
rock and hit somebody who's going to
complain about mortgage prices complain
about the cost of a vehicle complain
about their wages complain about but at
the same time no one's doing anything to
fix it George well they're they're
cutting back on retirement this is wild
historically High inflation forced a
quarter forced I love that term they
were absolutely forced a quarter of
Americans to slash their retirement
savings and a full 12 to quit saving
entirely over the last year
but on the other side we also have
record high credit card debt yep we're
seeing record numbers of helocs being
taken out and and record numbers of buy
now pay later when you say record we I I
want to hit this number George because
when you say record record numbers of
credit card debt I need you to
understand it's almost uh to to trillion
with a t that's a thousand billions and
a billion is a thousand Millions which
mean your brain just exploded with zeros
yeah that's just what happened right so
what this is telling us George is people
know there's a a problem they feel
there's a problem but they're going to
the wrong solution instead of saying hey
I'm going to stop borrowing credit card
debt or hey I'm not going to take out
any more you know any more of the equity
on my home instead they're doing things
like pulling back on their investing
using their savings you're you you feel
that there's a problem but you're using
the wrong solution in order to solve it
so let's try to help these people and
understand what you need to be doing
well there's a paradigm shift that has
to happen first because we can tell
people hey you should get out of debt
you should say from emergencies that's
all good and well but until you believe
that there is hope for the future until
you believe that the American economy
economy will recover like it always has
always time and time again then you're
not going to do anything about it when
you listen to Hope Stealers and you just
become a victim right if inflation is
the villain then you're always going to
be a victim I love that that's so true
you need to say that again George these
folks need to hear that again if
inflation is your villain then you will
always be a victim because guess what
inflation ain't going anywhere no it's
been here since the beginning of time
it's just that there's dinosaurs and
inflation yep so it's not going anywhere
it's been higher than it has been in the
past but if you are really your life is
out of control because inflation is up
four percent higher than it has been
then you were already screwed
financially that's right that's such a
good point you know I I'm not going to
sit back here and act like these these
things that are taking place aren't real
yes like people are feeling the pinch of
inflation that's a real thing people are
feeling like they can't spend their
money as willy-nilly as they once did
because that that is the fact like there
is a pinch going on right now but I
think like you the point you made George
is true these things they hype they
happen in Cycles right there there's
always times when the market is down it
always rebounds back up but you've got
to understand that that's just part of
this thing and if you are going to
continually take those reasons and say
this is the reason that I can't uh get
out of debt this is the reason that I've
gotta you know use credit cards to get
by or this is the then you're just those
reasons are just turning into excuses
for you because at some point you've got
to make that transition and go okay what
can I personally do because I I'm the
type of person whatever it is that
you're whining and in complaining about
there's probably something that you can
do personally to change it for the
better instead of waiting for some
external factor to come in whether it be
the government or whether it be for your
job to give you a raise because they may
not give you a raise you're telling me
the boss and the government aren't going
to change my life come on Jade here's
the thing the people who are complaining
these are the same people who fall into
these stats Americans spent 20.7 percent
more at restaurants than they spent on
groceries in 2022. now there it is wait
a second hold on so we're all struggling
and so we're gonna go eat out because
that's the solution well George your
spending problems you know it's cheaper
to eat I gotta say this in a voice do
George it's cheaper to eat in a
restaurant my time is worth more than
that I can't be at home making food my
time is more valuable than that they
just put the YouTube sound effect on
that is every YouTube commenter every
tick tocker out there and then Jade on
travel right Revenge travels back Delta
reported record Advanced bookings for
summer travel despite industry-wide
inflation and fares so air travel is the
most expensive it's been in a long time
and we're all out there going we're
going to book this thing six months out
on the credit card because we're going
to get the points we're going to use the
points we're going to hack the system
bro the system is hacking you it's
hacking you're the hack
yeah it's insane this is like an
intellectual inconsistency because on
this side you're you're saying oh it's a
problem this is not fair but then over
there it's like yeah but it must not be
that much of a problem because I'm still
going to restaurants I'm still going on
a trip to Hawaii and I'm still gonna
take out a car note for 717 because
that's the price of the average car note
right now and then let's talk about the
economy Jade because this is the true
fear but I have some perspective to
share that I think will make everyone
feel better what these are real numbers
in the last 40 years the S P 500 which
is the index that is used to really
track the stock market in the U.S in the
last 40 years the S P 500 was up 32 of
those 40 years that's right and get this
22 of those years there was a return
greater than 12 percent wow everyone out
there you mean you're making 12 well
dude you're looking at your 401k in the
last year or two have some perspective
the S P 500 was up over 12 percent for
22 out of the last 40 years I'm not
betting against the American economy and
I don't think you should either and when
you look at it the years that it was
down the next year it's rebounded right
back up so when it's down you're buying
on sale when it's up you are making some
sweet coin yeah and that's how you build
wealth you just leave it don't touch it
don't pull it out because you're scared
because you saw a headline and
especially don't turn to buy now pay
later and he locks as some kind of
Solution please all your problems please
please I I feel like we need to give
these people what the true solution is
because George you and I know it you
know like I said you guys feel that
there's a problem and you're right there
is a problem but the solution is not
borrowing more money you cannot borrow
your way out of debt you cannot borrow
your way out of financial strain you've
got to actually draw a line in the sand
you've got to stop borrowing money and
uh if you didn't hear we just announced
something that's very very very excited
uh me uh all the other personalities
George included Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman
uh John deloney all of us are excited
about this thing that we're doing guys
we are hosting
Financial Peace University all of us
we're all doing our own class and we
want you to join because we understand
how this can affect your life I got to
do this last month with a group of folks
and George the average turnaround was
ten thousand dollars in five weeks in
debt paid off in dollars saved yes five
weeks ten Grand 10 grand per per
household wow five weeks now think about
that think about how that would change
your life if you weren't worried about
inflation because you had a 10 000
turnaround you see the debt going away
you see the savings build up and you go
I'm less worried about the headlines
because that's not what changes my life
I mean this financial peace class if
you're listening we will you know give
you the link that is also on the YouTube
page my class starts May 8th George
yours starts June 20th and you can go
online uh and sign up fpu.com check it
out sign up today guys this is what
helped us get out this is what helped my
husband and I pay off almost half a
million of debt this is what helped
George pay off over 30 000 of debt this
is the plan and the plan works sign up
today this is your way out don't be
complaining anymore because we just gave
you to the solution you're not gonna
have an excuse after you go to our fbu
class this is the game right here it's
your chance to sign up uh head over to
the website now and do that Financial
peace.com this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw your host today I am joined
by fellow Ramsay personality George
camel and we are taking your calls give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
I've got William in Atlanta Georgia
Georgia ATL what's going on William
hey good afternoon guys I just want to
start off by thanking you guys for what
the entire Ramsay team does I mean when
I look at where my wife and I are
financially at 25 compared to our peers
or even those approaching retirement it
brings us an incredible level uh level
of peace knowing where we are so thank
you guys thank you so I I I I trust the
Ramsay team so that is why I have a
question about our HOA my wife and I
just purchased our first property and it
is a high-rise condo that we will use as
a rental property when we pay it off you
know it's in a fantastic location the
amenities are top-notch you know Jan
Pool movie theaters great staff it's
clean
um but one of the things that I don't
hear often when HOAs are discussed on on
the show or in the comments on YouTube
is you know the the HOA can kind of help
control the type of people you're living
with which tend to be you know high
functioning High performing
professionals which matters to me so so
that is why I was able to rationalize
getting into an HOA but I also recognize
being in my mid-20s having zero life
experience in the real estate space and
no wisdom in real estate but
um what I what I had just laid out made
sense to me and we pay 650 a month uh
but we're only a couple months in we
just purchased and seen a recent
conversation they've had with a caller
um being in a in in an HOA made me think
we may have stepped into something we
should not have
um so we can afford the HOA we've
studied the financials and everything
checks out but I'm just kind of
wondering what what could I be missing
here what are the dangers that I'm not
uh thinking about well what's your
mortgage payment with all the property
taxes homeowners insurance everything
included interest
yeah 20 2500 bucks
and then plus the 650 and that puts us
at 31.50 a month All In
yes sir and then once your after-tax
monthly
income
um after tax monthly income were right
around 12 000.
so then what you tell me then what's
your hesitation on this because we tell
folks you know when you're purchasing a
mortgage you don't want it all in
talking about taxes fees HOA payment you
don't want it to be more than 25 of your
take home and you're under that so
you're right at 26. so you're pretty
much spot on
so yeah yeah I mean we're good in that
I'm comfortable with that it's more so
just hearing that uh that conversation
uh the other day made me question
whether or not there may be something
that I'm missing being in an HOA for
example uh you know an unexpected uh
cost comes up where they're gonna Force
us to to pay and that can happen a
certain amount of money yeah everyone
goes all right we all got to chip in 10
grand to cover this that's that's a
that's a part of being a part of an HOA
yeah the fee can go up
um absolutely so there is some risk
there
um is there anything else I mean at this
point I guess my question is is it
enough that it would make you move on
because you're in the condo now
right no it's not and and again it's
it's fine we can afford it and and we're
we're we just got into our uh
professional career so our our
professional income is only going to
grow from here and
um and so I'm not too worried about the
HOA going up I'm just I'm I'm more so uh
wondering what other potential dangers
there are being in the natural way or
being a homeowner in the natural way
that I may not have considered I would I
wouldn't call it dangers it's just more
the annoyances of like all right we got
to follow the HOA rules if they say we
can't paint the door red we can't paint
the door red and so you know there's all
the kind of uh the parks and rec level
pettiness that goes along with HOAs and
the meetings and the frustrations but
yeah I've had an HOA on every single
home I've owned same and honestly
William the way Sam and I have tackled
that is usually Sam becomes part of the
HOA he tries to get on the board so that
he can have kind of a control a little
bit of a say in what's going on and kind
of see what's going on um sooner than
the other members might know what's
going on so I feel like if it's
something like that you might want to
see if you can get involved in it but
I'm like George I don't I wouldn't say
it's a danger just know that it's a
variable cost and it has the ability to
change over time as do you know your
your taxes could change over time you
know there's there's things that can
change when it comes to a mortgage so
that's why we teach it the way we do
because we want to make sure that you do
have plenty of margin if something like
that were to take place but very very
good question
um I like that if you're if you're
worried about it get involved with it
yeah and it sounds like William's about
to be the newest member of the HOA very
excited for him he seems like he like he
would make a good a good HOA but it
feels like like presidency you can only
last a certain number of years in the
HOA before the car I'm out guys I did my
part well as long as you do a good job
if you do a good job you can stick
around for a while but I'll tell you the
houses we've moved in the HOA man
sometimes it's like y'all aren't doing
anything we're just giving you our money
and a lot of times you come in and
there's just a giant pool of money
they're not doing what they should be
with it I'm like can y'all replace the
sign in the front can we get some new
trees planted here can we rip you know
and sometimes it is a good idea to get
involved with your HOA because you can
have a say-so and things you can get the
ball rolling on things and make sure
that your money is being spent the way
at least you want it to be spent and you
can convince others it's like Congress
that is what you have a little more
involvement you know I don't agree with
how they spend but I can raise my voice
and say I don't like it well guys um if
you're a new listener and you want to
dive deeper into the Ramsay baby steps
we want you to go to ramsaysolutions.com
and click the get started button uh
probably today you've heard George and I
talk about all sorts of things we talk
the lingo around here we're talking
about baby steps we're talking about
different rules and it's kind of a
Ramsey thing and we don't want you to
miss out so go to ramseysolutions.com
and click that get started button we'll
help you figure out the next best step
for you on your financial Journey based
on exactly where you're at today so
that's ramseysolutions.com get started
and as always we love that you guys
listen to the show we're here because
y'all are here we wouldn't have a show
if you didn't listen so we're extremely
grateful that you guys tune in day after
day whether it be podcast YouTube
whatever it is but hey we want you to
share the show we want you to tell other
folks about this if it's helped you if
you enjoy it or maybe you just find it
entertaining just click the like button
click the share button on whatever
platform that you're listening uh we
would really really appreciate that so
let's take another call real quick we
got Neil from St Louis Missouri what's
going on Neil
hey um I have a question I was
uh wondering about getting a HELOC loan
on my house no for a home Edition no
why do you what's this addition
all right so I have a house I blog for
130 000. uh really good you know
interest rate whatever I got five kids
and a sixth one on the way 1200 square
foot so I figured spend another 50 60
Grand uh would be cheaper than going to
buy like a 300 000 house you know so so
you're gonna basically build a mini
house on top of your house for 50 Grand
well oh yeah I got a lot I'm a
contractor so I can do a lot of work
myself so it cost me like 50 60 Grand to
hire out like the stuff I can't do like
foundation and stuff do you have any
debt uh
um I think yeah I got uh just my home
and then uh since I have so many kids so
fast I I bought a big van for 25 000 I
got a loan on that but I kind of I have
cash sitting there where I could pay it
off how much cash do you have in the
bank
um I got like with 30 Grand in my bank
and then uh like 40 Grand Investments
are these non-retirement
yeah just general mutual funds okay and
then uh cash in the bank for just like
kind of on the side for business and
payroll I always like to have a big
chunk just have for a couple months of
payroll and stuff okay
um so here's an idea I don't think
you're gonna do it but I'll tell you
what I would do if I was in your shoes
which is how we answer calls on this
show I would take that 70 grand I would
use a portion of it to pay off the van I
would then set up your fully funded
emergency fund to three to six months of
expenses and then once I have the money
beyond that to cash flow the renovation
on the house I would then do it but I
would not take a HELOC putting her home
at risk paying stupid interest and
setting you backwards financially that's
true and and the money that you have set
aside I agree with George wholeheartedly
the money that you have set aside that
you said was maybe for payroll in
business type expenses I just want to
make sure that you are managing that
money properly and that you're keeping
it separate from your personal money and
just know that whatever money that you
pull extra from that you're gonna have
to pay payroll taxes on it so just
understand what that's going to look
like and it's going to be a pretty penny
of that because you know Uncle Sam oh
yeah
the old capital gains on those
Investments as you pull them out that's
right and definitely no non-retirement
Investments investing my reserves feels
like a terrible idea because if the
market goes down I'm screwed that's
dangerous yeah that's true that's a good
point you want to have that cash on hand
well guys that does it for today's show
hey be sure to join us next time and
until then remember you can tell me you
won't do it but please do not tell me
that you can't With God all things are
possible
what's up guys it's Jade if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it is the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth we help people do work that they
love and we're helping you create and
build actual amazing relationships we
want to talk about what's on your mind
we want to talk about your money we want
to talk about your relationships give us
a call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and let's
just go straight to the phone lines I'm
your host Jade warshaw joined by George
Campbell and we're going to take your
calls so let's talk to Sophia she's in
Baltimore Maryland what's going on
Sophia
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call
um I'm calling because I dislike my job
I want to quit I want to find something
that's more aligned with me but I don't
know if I'm financially in the place to
do that
um and I was wondering if you guys could
help me figure that out and maybe make a
plan for the next step most definitely
so tell us about your job a little bit
what do you hate about it what's the
problem
sure so I'm a government consultant
I work eight hours a day at a desk I
just don't feel like I'm doing impactful
work
I'm a people person everything's room
nowadays and
I just I just don't feel like I'm making
an impact and I just am drained every
day at the end and I'm not excited to
get up to go to work the next day but it
pays really well and I have really good
benefits and there's safety there so
what do you make
uh 125.9
okay plus the benefits do you think
there's another place that would pay you
125 plus good benefits
yeah but I don't know if
what would satisfy like my soul and my
heart and what I meant to do would ever
pay that so I think maybe there's like a
little come to Jesus moment about just
accepting that maybe for me to be happy
I need to accept making less money so
what is that thing for you where
regardless of money if money was not an
object what would you be doing
I I
bought a couple years ago and I love
working on it I love like flipping
houses I love doing a lot of Hands-On
work um
I would maybe event planning teaching I
love to teach I would love to teach at
like a community college or something
um those are the big ones for me
um but I'm also at a point where I'm
figuring out you know what is my true
calling so I'm still in that window
phase so is it you said flipping you
love creative things events teaching so
is it like transformation that you like
to see is that what that's the common
thing that I see there returns I don't
like working on something for years and
maybe not really seeing results
um and I like helping people that's the
government
are you single are you married
I have a boyfriend
um but he's definitely going to be my
husband so awesome okay call me in a
couple years so tell us about your
financial situation do you have any debt
do you have any savings
yeah so
um I would be uh what you called a
stupid butt or whatever I've made some
bad choices so I'm on about 307
000 in debt but the majority of that is
house okay aside from the house what's
left in consumer
so I have about 1500 credit cards
um I have a payment plan
um for a treadmill that I got I know
stupid and then also I needed some roof
work don't have a slate roof so that was
really expensive the 1500
um payment on that um I have the payment
is 1500 What's the total amount of the
roof
um Turtle Mountain the roofing work with
1500. okay I took another loan when I
was buying my house against David Steven
I can't believe I could say this out
loud definitely come to Jesus moment um
uh is um out on my term life I took some
cash out to help me um get my like 25
000 down payment on my house and then I
owe my dad four thousand dollars he
doesn't want it back but I want to pay
him back can you help me buy myself so
what's the total amount of Consumer Debt
you have
um would be about 45
000. whoa so there was some numbers in
there you weren't mentioning it I was
like oh looks like 10 grand or so here
yeah do you have any money set aside do
you have any money set aside for savings
I have my 1000 emergency fund and I'm in
the middle of paying everything off um
so I have a car loan and then also a
personal loan stupid I know stupid
stupid it's okay it's okay Sophia don't
be yourself we've all been there I'm
just kidding yeah we're not going to
jail you today what's your plan
um
so basically have end of the month I
have about 3 000 cash balance left over
after all of my budgeting and I've just
been throwing that at my you know
smallest Betsy snowballing but
um my car 17 000 less than that it's
about 22 24 000 in value
but here's the thing when you look at
that car and go that's what's keeping me
from the next job that makes me want to
sell the car even heck yeah we got to
get to this place of Happiness where
you're feeling content with what you do
on a daily basis so there's a two-fold
plan here number one is the baby step
which you're currently following stay on
track for that sell the treadmill sell
the car and then on top of that I would
be sharpening up the resume I'd be
looking for jobs out there even if it's
a slight pay cut for now uh-huh now what
about not having three to six months
emergency savings is that you need that
eventually you need to look for a new
job while not having that safety net
here's you're not going to just quit
willy-nilly with no job lined up that's
that's what we don't want is a gap in
income so as long as there's no Gap in
income you'll be okay you can switch
jobs while on the baby steps absolutely
you can but you also have to look at the
opportunity costs there because right
now you've got a three thousand dollar
margin and if we really look at this and
figure out like how long you can
realistically pay off this forty five
thousand dollars of debt it might be
worth it now this is just me you've been
in this job it might be worth it to
stick it out another year to get this
debt gone and then when you transition
you know get that three to six months
saved up and then when you transition it
can feel a lot more peaceful and you can
just really just step into this new
phase of life so there's something to
think about there
um because remember from what you've
said and we don't we haven't done the
research fully yet but you think that
you're going to take a decent pay cut
you might you might not you need to
check and see what's out there but if
you do find that it's uh you know maybe
your pay starts in half because you're
starting at the bottom you have to weigh
that out and go is it going to be worth
it for me to go from a three thousand
dollar margin to a fifteen hundred or a
thousand dollar margin
um and you know only you can decide that
but I am always about getting out of
debt as quickly as possible and you can
go do event planning on the side you can
help event planners on the side and get
your feet wet and also create a little
extra income like that yeah yeah I am I
also do some grading for a university so
I get between the
water grading and awesome I have a whole
I have a whole life policy that I can
cash in because I know you guys aren't
into like life insurance and whole life
especially but if I just make sure
you've got the term life coverage make
sure you've got the term life coverage
in place before you cancel the whole
life
um on that and I mean I think this is
really exciting for you
I appreciate it okay thanks for the call
I'm gonna get rid of the car yeah do it
do it wow I love love a live amputation
on air it feels good I feel Freer like
amputated the car that's exciting I
think she's really going to change her
life here I want to give her paycheck to
purpose if she's still on the line
awesome will you pick up and give her uh
Ken's book pages Ken's get clear
assessment oh I like that even better
and combo from our friend Ken Coleman
that's going to help you find work you
love I love it man she's on the right
track I'm excited for her this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
by their one they're 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality and I'm
joined by George Campbell my host and uh
I think we want to just go straight to
the calls today so if you want to give
us a call we'll talk about your life and
money you can give us a call the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five give us a call and we'll chop
it up with you in the meantime let's go
to Noah he's in Tampa Florida let's see
what Noah's talking about what's going
on Noah
hey guys thanks for taking my call yeah
no problem how can we help cool yeah got
a quick question
um so I currently have a truck that's on
lease and it's due at the end of the
year
um I'm able to make the payments and
still put away 15 of my retirement and
still stack up in my emergency fund but
I like the idea of aggressively putting
away more money due to the current
market conditions with the auto and the
cars I'm sure you guys know I have
equity in the truck so I was thinking of
getting out of the lease early while I'm
up and buying a junker instead should I
wait to pay the truck off at the end of
the lease or should I just buy a junker
now
if I'm you if I can get out of it and
not have to pay I'm getting out of it
so you've got to find out the early
buyout amount have you done that
homework
I have yes sir what's that amount
the buyouts can be thirty thousand and
how much money do you have right now
I have about 70 000 savings heck yeah
I'm for sure doing that
what's the truck worth
the truck is worth 42.
so we do the early buyout which is 30.
we have we can then sell it for 42 and
net 12 and that'll buy us a car right
plus if you have you know do you have
any other debt
uh just my mortgage that's it great so
essentially you would actually be a baby
step four tomorrow if you got rid of
this car and got a junker because right
now you've been doing all the steps at
once
yeah I absolutely agree I'm only hung up
on
um if I should get the drunker or if I
should pay it off and then work at
getting the amount put back in my
savings account that I use to pay off
the truck that was my only cost what's
your income
about 175 right now do you like the
truck do you want to keep it
I really do like the truck um I had it
since 2001 right before everything
started going crazy before covid
um so I really do enjoy the truck I love
it a lot I lived here in Florida
um where you know the truck is pretty of
a utility so why not keep the truck
I'm not mad at that that's what I was
thinking but my only thing was if I save
the rest just buy a junker for 15 and
take the difference and just put it back
into my like savings account what's the
savings for
nothing I don't have any kids or
anything just to have it so let's say
let's walk through this you keep the
truck you're down to 40K in savings
which we'll call three to six months of
your emergency fund plus a little bit
right
yes sir and we're back on track let's
continue investing 15 any extra money we
can throw at the house so even in that
savings account anything beyond six
months I would throw at the mortgage
and get that mortgage out as soon as
possible yeah well what's left on the
mortgage
uh 200.
so you said you make 170
175 yes sir and so I start to get
excited going making 175 how quickly
could I pay off a 200 000 mortgage I
know that so use your guys's calculator
and it comes out to about four and a
half uh four and a half years and I bet
you'll beat that I bet so too
yeah and so that's my only expense right
now yeah I'm I'm following this plan you
like the truck keep it there's no need
to go buy a junker that you hate you're
going to want to upgrade and probably
make a bad decision down the line just
keep the truck you make great money it's
not a big portion of your world the
thing we want is it to be paid off very
cool I love that call again options
George we've seen this all the time a
very cool call when you get to you can
keep the car well it's great when they
actually want to get out of debt a lot
of the times they go why would I pay off
the car Jade when I can make more in my
investments I'm like oh you found the
secret formula to always make money in
the stock market tell us more my friend
please stock market was down 18 last
year everyone's going well dude I can
make more in the stock market well
that's funny I feel like that's one of
those arguments when they want it to
work it works and when it doesn't
because when we tell you to invest your
car payment you know instead of paying
seven 717 a month suddenly people are
like you can't make any money on the
stock market right I'm like What's
Happening Here it's got to work on both
sides the train can't leave
justification station for a lot of folks
out there
stuck oh gosh well today's question of
the day is sponsored by neighborly this
is your hub for Home Services if you own
rental properties neighborly's local
Real Real Property Management offices
can manage them and help you optimize
your Roi and your peace of mind visit
neighborly.com to schedule a
consultation with Real Property
Management Pros near you today's
question comes from Nick in Florida I
know you don't recommend credit cards
but what are your thoughts on debit card
extra and prepaid charge cards that say
they help build your credit
so extra is the name of a specific debit
card company out there that kind of
operates like a credit card by helping
you build your credit because they spot
you so just make a purchase and you
temporarily go into debt and then
they'll spot you and pay it off quickly
and so that's the idea behind extra and
it's similar to some of these prepaid
charge cards secured it's technically
not one of these secured credit cards
yeah and the way secured credit cards
work is you pay an upfront deposit of
one to two times your credit limit and
if you don't pay they keep your deposit
that's what makes it secure there's
collateral involved yeah but with with
these extra cards here's what I don't
like a I don't like that they're
marketing it as a debit card because
technically that makes it sound like
you're using your own card and they're
just monitoring your accounts and that's
not true at all you do have to spend on
their account yep and they and I
actually I don't know I actually called
extra because I wanted to know more
about this
um because I've had other people ask
about this and I asked them I was like
so how does this work and he was like
you spend the money on our card first
and then we go back in your account pull
the funds out but it can take three to
up to three days for them to pull that
money out so if from the time that you
make that purchase as many times do if
something comes out of your account
unexpected and suddenly you don't have
you can't fit the bill for 300 or
however much you spent on your extra
card suddenly like that has the ability
to go to collections and they'll send it
to collections within 30 days yes and so
the heart of this is to build credit the
people who are using this product they
have bad credit they have mismanaged
money they haven't made payments instead
of going well I may not be able to get
the credit card it has higher interest
so I'm going to turn to this extra card
here's the problem extra ain't free it
costs you 240 to 300 bucks a year
depending on the plan you choose and
then the other thing they get you with
is oh we have rewards too so they're
using the same marketing tactics as the
credit card companies to get you to
overspend with money you already didn't
have which is part of the reason you
have bad credit to begin with that makes
sense I mean there's even been I mean
yes is the bad credit people but then
there's even been people who are like
hey I'm kind of like doing you guys's
plan ish but I still kind of care about
my credit score maybe I can use this to
still kind of have a credit score even
though I don't want to borrow money in
quotes and I think like that's just one
of those dangerous things where it's
like hey you you gotta you gotta buy all
into this you either are saying I don't
I'm living a life without debt I don't
care about my credit score and I can
rock my life with a zero credit score or
you're on the fence and you're playing
in these games where you mess around and
get you get burned man yeah at the heart
of the question of building my credit
the solution is not to build your credit
it's to get rid of it facts and that
scares so many people because we've
believed the myth and we've touted this
myth that FICO is Almighty and you gotta
have a good score to survive and I'm out
here going what do you need a score for
to go into more debt and what does that
do helps you get a better score if you
pay it off perfectly and play kissy face
with the bank so that you can go get
more debt yes and the only legitimate
question is well how do I get a house
without a credit score and I made a
whole video about this on my new YouTube
channel Jade because I was so angry at
everyone going this guy's lying after I
said no I'm telling you I did it I'm not
like pitching this as a theory Jade has
done this too yes and I have to say this
because I look I'ma catch the Flack for
it but I he I see you guys in the
comments talking about well George is
easy for you you've got white skin no no
I'ma squash that I'm gonna put the smoke
on that right now thank you it does not
matter what you look like if you are out
here in in these Americas in this United
States you can pay off your debt you can
live a life with no credit you can get a
zero credit score loan I did it I've
done it before so don't just say oh
George did it because of the way he
don't be judging a book by its cover my
dad's from Egypt okay I know another
language what do you know
Jack squat oh type down in the comment
section come through George I'm proud of
you thank you speak up on that and James
here I feel Brave and the thing is we're
is we're trying to yell at you we just
want you to know what's possible we
don't
believe all that noise out there that
says that it's impossible for
someone like me to get ahead that's not
true we believe more for you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host today Jade warshaw Ramsay
personality and I'm joined by one of my
favorite co-hosts of all time George
Campbell I'm talking to you means a lot
there's only like four you can choose
from so I appreciate being one of them
at least you know you know that you're
in the top four that's great
we're taking calls today about your life
your money give us a call the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George it's National financial
literacy month the cool kids call it
finlit a and we're taking I don't think
I'm one of those kids but you are no I
do that look somebody said that to me
the other day I was like what the heck
are you talking about and they're like
financial literacy I was like well why
didn't we just call it that but the cool
kids say finlit and we're talking today
uh taking today to celebrate that
financial literacy is very very
important stuff guys and it needs to be
taught in school I don't know about you
but I'm one of those folks who was like
I didn't learn it didn't learn a dang
thing I got the Pythagorean theorem down
pat but I have no idea didn't know
anything about taxes wow none of it it's
crazy why weren't we taught how to
budget in school why didn't anyone tell
us that we should stay away from credit
cards or show us how to save money they
didn't do any of that think of all the
dumb mistakes I can think of a lot of
dumb mistakes that I could have avoided
if we had been taught this
um well the good news is we're changing
the game out here yes with our
foundations and personal finance
curriculum which I had the pleasure of
Hosting I got to meet some of the high
schoolers that are going through this
Jay yeah I was like a little celebrity
to them it was hilarious I was like
y'all need to get out more why were you
a little celebrity well for obvious
reasons but obviously so you know it's
just it's through a curriculum in a
school yes but the kids were like man
I'm gonna go to college debt free I'm
paying cash for my first car and I was
like we got future millionaires here and
the curriculum is now taught in over 45
percent of schools in America that's our
incredible that gives me hope that's
incredible well this is really cool
today we have one of our foundations
teachers she's on the line we've got
Michelle from Tulare California uh on
line five let's talk about what's going
on Michelle
good morning or good afternoon I don't
know what time zone you're in uh we're
in Central Time Zone where are you
we are in California all right so we're
Pacific
cool cool cool cool
um well I just you know we wanted to
take a moment and celebrate you today
and just celebrate you and see what's
going on uh we want to know about what
you're teaching your students and how
many students you have in your class can
you tell us
yeah I teach at accelerated Charter High
School it is a charter through our local
uh district and we are a credit recovery
high school so kids come to us their
Junior and Senior year to help make up
credits at an accelerated rate oh so
that they can graduate on time or with
their friends at their home school
that's awesome that's really really cool
so like how many folk like how many
grades are you teaching how many folks
have been through this with you
well this is our seventh year of
existence it is my seventh year teaching
Ramsay classroom I started it when we
had the workbook and the videos on DVD
that you showed the whole class wow and
we progressed yeah seriously and we have
progressed to the online curriculum and
the kids can work on it at their own
pace or I can choose to watch or show
the videos and it just works out really
really well that's really exciting so
George mentioned uh before we brought
you on that we had a bunch of students
here yesterday and they were just going
on and on about you know how it's
affected them and they're going to be
future millionaires do you have any
success stories that you want to share
whether from current students or
previous students about how this is
really changing and impacting their
lives
it's changing students lives
tremendously I have kids tell me you
know this is the only class that makes
sense it's the only class that applies
to Real World stuff
I have had several students come back to
the school to you know pick up paperwork
transcripts whatnot and if they see me
they say hey I'm following what you
taught us I'm using only cash I don't
have any debt and I have friends who
have dad and they're miserable wow so
thank you for teaching me I also want to
point out that it's not the students who
are the only ones benefiting from this I
benefited from it I have no debt except
for my house and uh we have an
administrator who has also taken the
courses offered and has applied them and
is also credit card free wow awesome you
know I also got to wonder how it's
affecting the students parents oh
because the kids are now going Mom and
Dad no no we're not going to use that
credit card you know what that's doing
to you do you hear stories about that
Michelle are the parents upset with you
going what are you teaching my kid
no actually when I meet with them like
at back to school night or you know open
house that kind of thing they actually
thank me because their kids are helping
them to budget their money wow that
something I love that gives me hope for
the Next Generation Well when the kids
are keeping the parents accountable
we're doing something right in America I
love this so what's like what's one of
the most common questions that you get
from your students when you're teaching
this class like is there anything that
they're kind of hung up on or is it
getting excited about yeah
oh they're hung up on credit scores
oh that's crazy that a 16 year old's
already freaking out about their credit
score they need to be freaking about
their prom date yeah not their credit
score right right no they uh because
it's been early indoctrinated in them
that they need to have a high credit
score their parents tell them that their
grandparents tell them that aunts and
uncles tell them that so when they come
to me and I say something different it
ends up not an argument but it becomes a
lively discussion I bet it's a nice way
to put it Michelle I bet
that's something well Michelle we're so
grateful for you you are I mean you said
it yourself you're out here changing
lives you're changing these children's
lives you've changed the lives of fellow
teachers around you probably impacting
the parents as well so we really really
thank you thanks for hanging with us and
thanks for coming on the line today with
us today
I appreciate the opportunity and
pleasure absolutely and for any teachers
that are listening don't forget uh to
enter the Ramsay teacher appreciation
giveaway it's sponsored by the Army
National Guard and one teacher guys is
going to win a five thousand dollar
vacation now George that ain't nothing
to sneeze at let's go five thousand
dollars and two more teachers will earn
a three thousand dollar Vacation all
you've got to do is go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher to enter again
ramseysolutions.com teacher to enter man
that is cool that's something right
there very exciting teachers are heroes
they are heroes just warms my heart
talking to teachers excuse me hope I
agree it gives me hope too well let's go
back to the phone lines we got Jeffrey
from Sacramento California what's going
on Jeffrey
hi guys thanks for taking my call how
are you
I'm doing well so I've just recently
tried to figure out what my 401k is and
I found out that I could switch it over
to a Roth so I did but I was wondering
what I should do with the 90 000 I have
in it right now should I switch that
over to a Roth and just pay the taxes on
it now and just not worry about it or
should I just keep letting that grow and
deal with that when I retire
where are you at financially
uh you have any debt I am no and my
house is paid for whoa way to go
fantastic
wow how old are you
I'm 35 but there's a caveat I got into a
really bad motorcycle accident so I was
I had a settlement payout so not the way
you want to become debt free but we're
here no how are you doing now
like uh physically I am physically I uh
lost the function of my right arm
so I am still with the same company but
I definitely decreased in my pay um
what's your household income now
um household income is around 70 right
now it was around 120. okay and do you
have the cash to cover the tax bill for
this conversion
um I believe yes yes I do okay
so this is the time we would say it
would make sense to do a Roth conversion
when you're in baby step seven you have
no debt including your home it's all
paid for and you have the cash on hand
to cover that tax bill so I would be
doing the math and get ready to pay that
bill but sure roll it over man
retirement that money is going to be all
completely uh tax-free to you which
feels good when you look at that account
number
absolutely all right thank you so much
for the call Jeffrey that's a good
question I think a lot of people wonder
you know when's a good time to roll over
if you've got money that's sitting in a
traditional and you want to because
we're always preaching Roth but don't
convert it until baby step seven because
you got you got priorities before baby
steps that's true you gotta wait till
baby step seven and then it's a good
time to do it that's a really great call
I think that's a question a lot of folks
have all right thanks for listening guys
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm your host today Jade warshaw
joined by George Campbell fellow Ramsay
personality and uh here's a fact about
Ramsay Solutions and I'm super duper
proud of this we've never laid off
anyone
ever
and I felt good about that coming into
this role I don't know about you George
Campbell a lot of fear out there in the
in the job market with all these
companies doing layoffs yeah no worries
over here I know I bet Dave feels good
about that for the past 30 years we've
been doing what we preach we run a
cash-based business here at Ramsey
solution which means that we budget for
everything that includes salaries
competition compensation for team
members and you deserve the right to
work for someone that you trust I
believe that wholeheartedly someone who
won't cut you loose because of their
poor planning can I just interject I was
on a podcast today talking to a friend
and she's in the tech industry and got
laid off and she was explaining how it
was like a little more than a text it
was like hey you don't work here anymore
and within 30 minutes she was locked
basically locked out of the company no
more access to email no more access to
any I mean just like that and she said
she had a sense that it was coming and
she had actually talked to a leader
about it
um you know I'm sensing this and they
said no no every everything's fine
everything's good and within a couple of
weeks out of there wow terrible so you
you deserve to work for someone you can
trust someone who won't cut you loose
because of their poor planning and guess
what while other people are firing
Ramsay's Solutions is still hiring we
have several open roles on our marketing
our sales and Technology teams and we
need people like you to come join us
come work alongside us we're way more
than just a radio show we help people
build real wealth we help them do work
that they love and create connected
relationships in a common sense but also
in a very counter-cultural way which you
hear us talk about on the air all the
time if that sounds like something that
you want to be part of we would be
honored for you to apply uh check out
all of the open roles at
ramseysolutions.com careers and you can
apply at ramsesolutions.com careers
that's what I did and it worked and it
worked so you gotta be as awesome as
Jade well you know close to it you know
we could talk about that later in the
meantime we will take a call from Steve
and he's in Asheville North Carolina
what's going on Stephen
hey Jade and George glad to be speaking
with you all honor to talk to you man
what's going on
uh so I was calling my wife and I bought
a house about a year ago and
um I think it's well I know that based
on the Ramsey plan it's definitely more
than we can afford
um we've been following you guys for a
long time and we're in steps four and
six now we don't have any kids
um but I think the house that we have is
a little bit more than you know we kind
of bit off more than we can chew it's a
30-year mortgage we can we're making the
payments fine on the 30-year but if it
was a 15-year it'd be kind of tight so
how much are the payments and also how
much are you taking home every month
after taxes
so our take-home pay for the past year
couple years really it's been pretty
steady
um anywhere between like 7200 and 7 600
a month
um
and the payment is like 17.49 a month
and so you know that's like 23 or
something down
yes it's like 23 25 but that's on a
30-year sure so is the issue that you
want to pay this mortgage as though or a
15 or more or like are you considering
you're not considering refinancing I'm
guessing you just want to do it as a
15-year
pay it as though it were so I guess my
question is like should we sell it and
is it worth the whole selling it and
paying the
um you know the capital gains taxes on
that and getting us into a home that is
on a 15-year fix you know I don't think
this is an on fire situation Stephen
which there's something deeper here
going on because that's just the
financials the numbers here you guys
still have plenty of margin every month
you have no debt and your mortgage
payments 17.50 you're making 7 500 a
month where's all the other money go
that you guys are feeling so tight
um well we've had some medical bills the
past year not not anything major I mean
there's been some dental work
um little minor car repairs here and
there but if we were to take like the
extra
I mean when I punch it in your
calculator we should be paying around
2500 a month
um to pay it off in 15 years and that
kind of makes things tight that's that
puts us at like 35 or 40 percent that's
what I'm confused about yours that's an
extra 750 right so that's how much
margin we need to pay it off like a 15.
why can't we find 750 out of 7 500.
I don't know I was thinking it was more
like a thousand or twelve hundred
dollars the math I did I'm just looking
at the numbers you shared okay yeah yeah
yeah no you're right
so let's attack this from a couple of
thoughts number one I'm with George I'm
wondering where this money is so are we
doing a budget still or is it kind of
like Hey we're on baby step four and six
we don't need that we don't need that
anymore we're going we don't need budget
we're in we're in every dollar probably
way too often
um I mean we look at it at least every
weekend we don't have the plus so we're
we're tracking all of our stuff on our
own all the expenses
um but we're in every dollar we do a
monthly budget every single month
um and it just seems like the things
keep creeping up and the mortgage isn't
getting extra attention that it should
we're we're putting 15 away
um we are
you know I mean I I well that's my
question
here's the thing and this is not just
for you Stephen this is for anybody
listening because a lot of times you
know what do we hear all the time I'm
not sure where the money is going it's
just stuff happens and things pop up and
that's the way it is almost as though we
have no control of it but we do have
control over how that money is being
spent and if I'm real it sounds like you
guys are deciding how you if you're
doing a budget you're deciding how that
money is being spent every month and
when you are in baby steps four five and
six there is a level of intentionality
that needs to take place if you want to
pay off the mortgage
um there are plenty of people who have
caught on to the baby steps later in
life and they already had a 30-year
mortgage and the point is not for you to
feel guilty or feel like oh man I I did
bad and now you know you don't have to
rush out to change that but of course
you do not want to take 30 years to pay
off this mortgage and I love that you're
trying to pay it like a 15-year mortgage
um and it's not to say that oh I've got
to sell this house and go get another
house on a 15-year fix like that's not
what we're telling you to do I think
what you're attempting to do is great
pay it as though it is a 15-year
mortgage but you've got to accept the
fact that you're the one who sits down
and writes that budget every month so if
the money is going somewhere you decided
where it went and you've just got to go
back in and say okay maybe our lifestyle
is crept up a little bit more or maybe
we're you know and I'm not I'm not
saying that there is not a time for it
to creep up a little bit more but if
it's keeping you from doing an
intentional act that you know you need
to do then it's time to rebalance that
absolutely and Stephen I'm gonna gift
you every dollar premium because you
said you're using the free version right
now I think this will help when those
transactions just immediately pop up
it's connected to your bank you can also
use their paycheck planning tool in
there there's some really cool Financial
roadmap and goals tools that will keep
you on track so if you'll use that I'll
give it to you for free hang on the line
and Austin and Skyler will pick up we'll
get that over to you but this is a
common
question Jade people are going I make
good money I'm even following the steps
yeah we don't have any debt where is our
money going so I like to do a little
thing called the budget audit oh and it
sounds scary but it's kind of fun and
what you do is you have every single
expense listed out you have a zero based
budget income minus expenses equals zero
okay and then we ruthlessly go through
every single line item ruthless and go
are we doing the best we can with this
category yeah do we still need it are we
overpaying for insurance and we haven't
shopped it with our friends over at
Xander in a while let's go reshop our
insurance premiums someone messaged me
the other day they said dude I did that
I saved 500 bucks you should do that
every year yes at least so that's one
area food is the other area yeah even
when you're in babysat four through six
you can't just go eat out whenever you
want no you can't you can't it will add
up faster than it'll make your head spin
so those are the two biggest areas is
food and insurance and then the
subscriptions oh my we're addicted we
got subscriptions for the subscription
shade it's out of control can I can I
admit something my subscriptions
it's it's a lot I have a lot of
subscriptions George I I have the
subscriptions
[Music]
[Applause]
I might need to do an audit of my
subscription so if I do it y'all gotta
do it with me okay I just did a video on
my new YouTube channel about the
streaming service Wars and how they're
we're all going to be casualties and how
to rise above it so and I found out
people are spending over 100 bucks a
month just on subscriptions yeah we
don't need the peacock app we don't not
if we have Amazon I'm talking to myself
right now Jade you got Amazon you don't
need peacock Jade you've got Netflix do
you really need Hulu cut it probably not
the wine of the month club the Peloton
the Birchbox they're all over don't
don't put me on don't put that evil on
Me George because I don't have Birchbox
and I don't have Peloton but I do have
scentbird oh I know that's for another
time I know all right that does it for
this hour guys be sure to join us next
time and remember this when it comes to
changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but do
not tell me that you can't With God all
things are possible hey George camel
here if you love the show and you want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we've
got a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth we help you do work
that you love and we're helping you
build actual amazing relationships not
just Tick Tock and Facebook and
Instagram relationships with friends
that aren't real friends George they
ain't helping to pay the bills
get rid of them get rid of them I'm your
host Jade warshaw I'm joined by the
um ever lovable
George Campbell I love to see what the
intro is going to be every hour it's
always a journey you never know what
it's gonna ever lovable is not something
I've been called before so I appreciate
that that's that's what it is give us a
call you know the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five George
will give you great advice he might get
he might get a little snippy on you I'm
I think you're more likely to get snippy
I'll cut you with snark he'll cut you
with a snark we're going to take a call
we got Kara from Detroit Michigan what's
going on Cara
hi there
um I had inquired about long-term care
insurance one option that I was
introduced to is called variable
universal life insurance policy with a
long-term care writer so basically I
could put a sum of money say 75 000 and
it would be invested in mutual funds I
could allow it to grow for about 40
years when if I needed long-term care
that would get multiplied by four and
that becomes the amount I can use for
long-term care so my question was is
this worth looking into or is this more
on the whole life insurance side that
you guys advise us to avoid it is it's
more of the cash value whole life
insurance side that we would tell you to
avoid
um but can I just say I love that you're
thinking about long-term care how old
are you I'm 45
um I know it's early but I um I'm just a
little hyper focused right now on
getting all my ducks in a row due to
some
um
the family storms that I've had so
um so it's just something I looked at
not not really knowing when I should
look and then this was an option
introduced to me because of my age yeah
you know usually with long-term care we
suggest not even putting it into effect
until the day you turn 60 years old
um okay it tends to be pricey
um but that's the time where you want to
lock it in so you would be early to the
game on that and in the meantime just
pick up a term life insurance policy yet
I do have that
um uh so I really wasn't looking at this
for the life insurance portion it was
more for the long-term care so I'm all
set with the life insurance because I
just wasn't sure if I should Who Sold
you on this scam then yeah well I did I
haven't I haven't
um
proceeded with it it's just something
that was introduced to me yeah but like
where was it introduced from was it a
person did you find it online I'm just
curious as to how you stumbled on it yep
a financial advisor uh are you single
uh yes okay
um can I just ask you for questions
because what I'm thinking here is it
sounds like you're kind of a Savvy
person who's trying to do the best they
can with their money do you have any
debt
I do not you do not here's the thing if
you keep going the way you're going you
might be at the point where you could
like self-insure through this like if
you really you know by the time that
that point comes if you're still you
know unmarried or you know maybe you do
get married and he's got his money in
order as well you know you might get on
down the line and you have a couple
million in retirement and you're able to
self-insure through this but I and the
way it's going it might be that way but
I definitely wouldn't give my money to a
universal life insurance for them to
invest it at a crappy rate of return you
know where you could invest your own
money the same amount and get a much
better rate of return and control what
the money is invested in
or they say it multiplies by four I
think that was kind of what
um it's a lot of BS and empty false
promises on their end honestly okay
um you can do so much better investing
yourself in the stock market through
mutual funds than any return because
guess what they're getting their fair
share through the super high maintenance
fees
um all kinds of fees that are baked in
there and so your cash value starts to
get depleted and over time that premium
keeps going up which eats away your cash
value and so it's a terrible terrible
scheme they're running over there and
your financial advisor is actually just
an insurance agent that's cosplaying as
a financial advisor and so I would
recommend you very politely but firmly
and kindly fire them and find someone
who has your best interest at heart
because truthfully anyone's selling you
a variable life insurance policy it has
their commissions at heart man that's so
true and think about it you're 45 years
old if you took a whatever sum of money
that you were going to invest in this
and you let it sit in the stock market
for the next 20 years the the rate of
return for the S P 500 for 20 years has
been about nine eight what is it 9.87
somewhere around there is the average
annualized return on that so that's good
to know that that's what you could you
know if you find the right mutual funds
to invest in that's I would rather do
that and have control over it than give
it to you know some Joker who's in
insurance but pretending to be you know
some sort of investment advisor
okay how's that make you feel
I mean I want to know I
want good when sure and you know uh
looking to buy well here's the good
thing is we don't make a commission on
this we're just talking to you as good
friends and so I kind of feel like
sometimes that's the one advantage we
have George is we don't make a
commission on giving you guys the advice
I'm glad we're on the front end instead
of you calling us saying hey I took out
a variable universal life policy with a
long-term Rider and now I feel like I
got screwed help me get out of it I'd
much rather help you avoid it on the
front end
okay you're doing a great job so just
stay the course don't fall for any traps
you're doing so well and they're going
to use kind of fear-mongering tactics to
tell you you're not gonna be able to
afford this you need us you need this
long-term care Rider you need this
insurance policy but the truth is
they're going to eat up all of your
wealth through fees and commissions that
you are going to call us 10 years from
now going I can't retire because I put
all my money into the stupid life
insurance policy that's true this stuff
drives me crazy and I actually been
working on a piece for this for a
YouTube channel let's hear it and let me
just tell you what's going on here so
all of these Universal Life policies
they're now being pitched as wealth
building tools I know on yes there's a
blonde girl and she's like you know
you're supposed to use life insurance
fire live it's called life insurance and
I'm like that sounded just like her
thank you I do a great I don't know what
that says about me that I do a great
Annoying female but there it is so these
policies are often sold to the naive
they're gullible they're vulnerable yeah
and they're sold by these insurance
sales people who are using the title
financial advisor red flag number one
that's a lie yes I don't know how
they're legally able to do that and
here's the truth this is crazy I found
out
um the it's not regulated and so it's up
to the states to patrol this all of
these life insurance scams out there and
so they're pitched at with all these
benefits right risk-free growth uh
except they lose value due to the fees
for years before they break even so they
have storage Aid so they say well you
can't lose money it's a zero percent
floor stock market's down you don't lose
any money but guess what when the stock
market's up you're capped yes good point
George please talk about that the market
was up like 28 in 2021 but guess what
you had that life insurance policy you
were stuck at seven percent growth yeah
and so it's insane so on top of that
there's these tax-free inheritance
except your inheritance is already
tax-free up to 11 million infinite
banking uh you're just borrowing your
own money with interest how dumb are you
to borrow your own money with interest
wow
don't fall for this y'all run away term
life is the only way to go invest the
difference Thank Me Later yeah insurance
is not meant for you to build wealth on
insurance is meant to replace your
income for those who depend on your
income so that if you pass away they you
can still take care of them even after
you're gone that's the purpose of income
or from of insurance it's not here to
make you you know Scrooge McDuck out
here this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Ramsay personality Jade
warshaw joined by George camel and the
number to call in if you want to talk
about what's going on in your life and
your money is triple eight eight two
five five two two five now here's the
thing I just want to stop for a moment
George and say thank you to all the
folks who listen to the show maybe
you're watching it on YouTube maybe
you're on that podcast thank you so much
for listening to the show we hope we
sincerely pray that this is helpful to
you that it's helping you move the
needle in your financial situation or at
the very least that is entertaining you
you know on your drive you know
if nothing else you know what does Dave
say some say the advice is worth what
you pay for it but if you love the show
we just want you to keep sharing it look
we asked you a while back to start
sharing the show and I feel like we went
from like number 15 or 17 all the way up
to number 11. you guys have really moved
the needle and we're grateful for that
so if you love the show like it like
click the little like button or the
little check mark whatever it is on your
platform that you're listening to it
share it with somebody else and just let
somebody know how much you enjoy this
show we would sure enjoy that and if
you've never left a review go ahead and
leave a review for us as well
um but just know make it nice please
don't don't don't say anything rude
because George you know he's a pit bull
he'll he might don't come at me my
people yeah he might bite your ankle on
it so I'm more of a Chihuahua that's
what I'm saying biting the ankles that's
like a pit bull like that's aggressive
and scary actually I was just like I
ain't messing with that thing all right
I'll be the pit bull and you be the
Chihuahua there we go there we go so
George you yet again you're
people send me this stuff on the
internet and I go this made me laugh I
want to share it with America and with
you Jade okay you have not seen this but
this is a headline that just tickled me
angry Morgan Wallen fan sends the singer
a four thousand dollar bill for a
canceled show
so if you don't know Morgan Wallen is a
is a big country singer out there what's
one of his songs I couldn't tell you
Jade I don't listen to that okay okay I
just wanted to check because I don't
know who the heck this is I don't know
but he's a big country okay he was on
The Voice or something like season six
which again I don't watch that show so
this woman though so Morgan Wallen
everyone's sitting there at the concert
and on the screen appears this message
saying Morgan Wallen has lost his voice
he can no longer perform get your
refunds at point of purchase oh so
everyone who has traveled to this
concert paid all this money is now very
upset because they only get the ticket
price back they get the ticket price
back and so one woman named Mandy who
attended the concert posted on Facebook
and tagged the singer with her Express
wish to pay for everything from their
outfits to gas and so she said since
you're offering refunds here's our
itemized bill for you and she listed out
on her Facebook post the expenses we'll
put it on the screen if you're watching
on YouTube Hotel 560 makes sense okay
okay tracking so far gas two tanks 80
bucks okay Hotel gas okay four tickets
1600 bucks who's paying 400 to see
Morgan Wallen I truthfully don't know I
don't know because I've never heard of
them that's some Taylor Swift money okay
four hundred dollars my outfit 120 bucks
husband's outfit 218 dollars Oxford
Grill House 235 is that a restaurant
Cracker Barrel forty dollars Los
paralleros 45
Rebel Rags I don't know what that is but
I don't want anything I think because
they wouldn't have the opportunity to go
had an opt-in for the concert 629 drinks
at the concert before it started by the
way 220 Morgan Wallen merch 235 whoa
grand total Jade
3982 dollars I gotta take my shirt off I
gotta take my jacket off y'all can you
imagine
billing an artist for four thousand
dollars for your own stupidity
and she put her cash app right there in
the post going I'll expect my refund
tomorrow thanks bro thanks bro yeah and
she ended it with some there's some
expletives in there it's a
family-friendly show but she said my
husband has gone with me to two concerts
ever in the 17 years we've been together
somehow I talked him into this one and
this happens well she's got so what do
you think is she entitled to a refund
for all of the other expenses outside of
her ticket um
no she's got Moxie she's got some grit
there I'll give I'll give her that but
here's the thing
um
yes it would be nice if they gave a
little bit more than the ticket price
here's as a vocalist I can say sometimes
you just get laryngitis many times I've
had to cancel two shows of my own
volition in my life and I hated every
moment and one of it because I had
laryngitis and everybody got back their
ticket price but I just want to know and
can you guys put in the comments
wherever you're watching do you buy new
outfits for a concert I didn't know this
was a thing do you buy a whole new
outfit now she's not on stage no one's
looking at what she's wearing but she
wants to feel cute okay and all that all
the eating out they chose to do that
Morgan Wallen didn't tell him that they
had to go to Roadhouse or Texas Grill or
wherever they went the most hilarious
part is the cheapest expense on this
whole list is Cracker Barrel so well of
course Cracker Barrel beating inflation
out there they're like we gonna get our
dumplings we're gonna make sure we get
our chicken and dumplings you know I'm
looking at it like you paid for a trip
that you weren't expecting to take yeah
you know and you missed out on the
concert ticket price back but she's
getting her ticket price back so 1600
bucks is back so I think it's unfair to
say that she's getting she needs four
grand back she's already getting the
1600 back yeah I'm not mad at that look
it took spunk for her to to step to
Morgan Wallen like that but I'm glad
that she did it took spunk to admit all
of that spending happened within a
24-hour period I don't think I would be
able to spend three grand in 24 hours no
me neither I want to know her budget and
the fact that she called him bro at the
end is it's pretty special bro yeah
great to the concert I mean what are
y'all getting are they charging like 19
for Bud Light these days they're turning
up oh gosh that's a lot for me so here's
the here's the teaching out of this if
there is one teach it uh posting on
Facebook maybe won't solve anything
here's the my question is are people now
going to send her money to her cash app
as kind of a joke and she's now gonna
make like 20 grand this is going to be a
GoFundMe moment
so there's one wow but number two budget
for your trips and concerts and don't
spend willy-nilly like if you're on a
budget and you spent that that's fine
clearly they were just spending
willy-nilly probably putting this on
credit cards that's right and here's
another teaching point because this
reminds me of the folks who were taking
out 401K loans to go see Beyonce I heard
about that this you can't do this we
can't spend three thousand dollars on
you want to spend that kind of money to
see Queen B you're going to be you're
gonna be broke you're going to be broke
good job George oh man dude let's take a
call we got to take somebody's call
Matthew from San Antonio Texas get us on
track buddy
hey how are you guys what's going on
hey so I'm trying to figure out
um I have two high school kids and I'm
trying to figure out what kind of
savings account that I need to set up
for them for their future I know you
guys have talked about compound interest
savings accounts and I don't know where
to find one
um and I don't know how much to put into
it or excuse me how much they are going
to be putting into it because we're
trying to teach them
um better spending habits and things of
that nature because Mom and I are doing
uh Financial Peace as well awesome so
this is for them to save money this is
not like college savings this is just to
help teach them about
their own managing their own money do I
understand that correctly
yeah their College is already paid for
okay awesome
that's exciting and where are you guys
at financially
uh well we're in the Army uh I'm in the
Army non-state home and uh we're working
on our financial piece because we have
three mortgages
um and we're
we're just getting started uh we're a
couple months into it okay do you have
any debt other than the mortgages
uh
um about 18 000 all of our cars are paid
for
um and just credit card debt okay and
how old are the kids
uh 17 and 15. cool
and are they wanting to have this
discussion or is this something you're
wanting to teach them
um they're pretty financially driven
um with this advantage in this
generation so we're kind of pushing it
towards that and they're looking at so
when I told my daughter the the
potential that she has to be able you
know in 20 years to be a millionaire she
went her ears clipped up and she's like
oh really and I'm just basically trying
to teach my girls that they don't have
to be financially dependent
um on a man or amen are they working
right now do they have earned income
yeah so one of them is a babysitter and
the other one has a job my 17 year old's
got a job at a at a retail store love it
I think you open up a Roth IRA for them
and they can watch that money grow very
slowly over time and you can get with
one of our smartvester pros at
ramseysolutions.com and they love
teaching young people about compound
interest how to set this up how to
choose the right mutual funds and I'm
proud of you man that's awesome changing
your family tree a 15 year old opening a
Roth IRA okay let's go I love that and
their college is paid for too so they're
going to come into the world with no
debt they're gonna have so much money
they're gonna just have run out of
places to give it away man What a
Wonderful World this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
are listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Ramsay personality Jade
warshaw joined by George camel fellow
Ramsay personality uh give us a call the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we'll take your
calls talking about your money situation
man maybe you're having issues with
budgeting maybe your spouse is tripping
and they're not on board with the plan
maybe your kids whatever it is is going
on in your money situation give us a
call we want to talk about that um and
let's go straight to the lines let's go
to Bobby and Albuquerque New Mexico
what's going on Bobby
hey guys uh I just had a question uh
actually uh Financial Peace saved my
marriage about seven years ago so uh I
owe a lot to you guys so cool
um uh but yeah my wife and I we we've
done your plan we've been following it
um uh about five years ago I left my job
uh which I rolled my 401k over to an IRA
uh my current job that I have
um you know I have fully funded 401K um
I'm actually putting 10 on it I'm also
part of the uh National Guard which I
have five more years and then I get that
nice pension
um and then so my question and we have
no doubt
um and my question is that Ira that has
been sitting there I think we lost like
15K in the past like couple years
um would that be better to put it
against uh throw it against my mortgage
because we owe about 160 uh left on our
house last time uh we had it appraised
during covid we got like a two percent
uh
rate uh with now we owe uh 160 on it uh
we get the Zillow or zestiment or
whatever homes.com where they kind of
measure it out it says it's worth like
350.
the way I look at it is I'm losing money
on the IRA and my home going up would it
be good to you know cash out that Ira
take those kind of well you didn't lose
any money in the ira you don't lose
money unless you take it out yeah sure
it's not going to remain that way it's
gonna
shift and go up at some point okay I
can't time the market but I can tell you
that it will
uh 42. okay yeah and that's what I've
been thinking too is like yeah you know
it is one of those things I'm like do we
do we want to pay off the house and be
completely debt-free and you know just
kind of right off in the sunset on that
or here's the problem are you you're
robbing Peter to pay Paul here because
you are severing your retirement account
if you do that you're going to have
income taxes plus a 10 early withdrawal
penalty all to have a paid for house but
now you can't retire
no no so that's Ira
um is from a previous job a 401k that I
that I had I still have my current job
401K that I'm still contributing that's
fully funded and healthy it's still
retirement savings though and you would
still win would turn into if you just
left it alone you're gonna be punching
yourself in the face
oh okay now here's the thing what's your
what's your income I mean let's talk you
wanting to pay off your home is a good
idea let's just talk about the right way
to actually accomplish that so what's
your what's your take-home pay
so I make about 140 a year
so how quickly can you pay off 160.
yeah and then by my uh my Guard pay too
so that's another like 10 grand so I
guess like around 150. all right here so
let's let's make a plan that you're
intentionally paying off this house well
before you know well before schedule now
I did have one question did I hear you
say that you're you said you have a
fully funded retirement and you're
contributing 10 did I hear that yeah on
my 401k yeah so on baby step four we
would say contribute 15 percent
15 percent
so I just wanted to throw that in there
just it was just something I heard off
key but
um so yeah so the other five I'm sorry
so I have all my notes here sorry uh so
I also have a tsp which is I guess the
military's version of that which I do
another six percent oh okay so that's
military pay okay so you're okay so
you're at 16 percent
yeah okay got it all right thanks for
clarifying that but yeah so with your
income left over how quickly can you pay
off this house well based on my
estimations this thing's gone under
three years
this mortgage because what we do I mean
since we refined or whatever
um we were doing the whole 13th payment
and then we'd do like a lump sum uh try
to at the end of the year
um uh to try to get it paid off faster
but yeah the three years that's I would
just if you can get it on autopay so
every month you pay your mortgage have
extra on the principal every single
month and then see if you can up it for
the next month and up it for the next
month because if you can start doubling
up on mortgage payments every month yeah
could you guys do that
I think it's possible I think we can
definitely do that uh you've got to
decide yeah because my my life's a
stay-at-home mom and you know we send
the kids to school but like in between
like their uh
uh college fund and everything else
expenses I mean we I'm pretty sure we
can double up on payments you've got to
pick the right place to feel the pain
you wanted to pay off the Home Mortgage
which is a great idea you were pulling
wanting to pull from the 401K not
realizing how much pain that truly would
cause you and now George is suggesting
another idea that's you know maybe a
little bit more intense
um also intentional and there's a level
of pain associated with that too because
it's like wow you know now I'm seeing
how I'm spending my money I might have
to cut back on certain areas if I truly
want to get this home paid for quickly
and so just understand you're there's
pain on both sides one is a good pain
and one is like a stupid pain so
they're pulling from the retirement
although you feel like you don't feel
that pain it's huge but what George is
suggesting you're feeling that pain in
the moment but just know that that's
ultimately the smartest
um solution here because there's no
there's no
um negative drawback of it other than
just you deciding okay I'm gonna do this
instead of that there's no penalty
there's no fee there's no I wish I had
and there's no definitely no loss of
Interest yeah go use our early mortgage
payoff calculator at ramsaysolutions.com
because based on my napkin math you put
four and a half Grand a month towards
the mortgage it's gone in three years
you put five grand towards it it's gone
in two and a half years and that will
put some pep in your step where you can
see the light at the end of the tunnel
thanks for the call Bobby that's a great
call
um yeah I think that's just one of those
things George I think sometimes people
feel that urgency they want to get
something done really quickly in their
finances and it's almost like you're
just looking for any other option any
shortcut you can find even if it means
pain later yeah I'll take some some Joy
right now but it's not the right way to
do it that's right it's not the right
way I think we've got time for another
call let's see uh we got Kate in
Charlottesville Virginia what's going on
Kate
hey Jade hey George it's so great to
speak with you guys you too what's going
on thanks I'm calling because I wanted
to know if my husband and I can go on
vacation in March of 2024. thank you for
asking for our permission first we
appreciate that March of 24 okay are you
guys debt free
so that's kind of the question I'm I'm
not sure if we're set free or not well
do you have debt is money that you owe
to anyone for any reason
okay so really the only that that we
have is on land that we want to build a
home on okay
all right how much money do you guys
have in the bank
you have about 75 000
in the bank wow what's left on this
landline
we owe 208 we want to throw 25
000 of that 75 at the land loan make 25
of that hour
emergency fund fully funded emergency
fund okay
and then we
have a little bit left
for
um
I guess it is kind of like dead we're
just we have money to pay off some work
that was done but the person hasn't
collected yet okay so we're holding back
that 25 good for that person what's your
income
we bring home about a 74 000 between the
two of us I am applying for more work at
this point in time after listening to
you guys for the last couple of months
what's the vacation going to cost
we're thinking seven thousand thousand
yes
a year from now basically
yes you know the land is your only music
vacation for those music lovers it's
music yeah it's going to be there
hopefully not a Morgan Wallen concert
here's the thing you've got this you've
got this land I think that in 2024
hopefully you've made more
more gone forward with it and paid off
more of it if you're spending seven
thousand dollars on a vacation make sure
you're paying cash and make sure you've
got that three to six months saved
that's what I would do if it's above the
emergency fund it's not messing with
your other goals pay cash for it don't
put it on the credit card do you use
debit you don't want to be paying for
this vacation six months after you've
taken it I know especially if they
cancel the concert
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw Ramsay
personality sit next to me on my right
George Campbell fellow Ramsay
personality and as always we're taking
calls here man your life your money give
us a call Triple A
825-5225 the scripture in quote of the
day
but Jesus often withdrew to the
Wilderness for prayer
I love that sometimes you got to go to
the Wilderness yeah what was that from
Luke 5 16. um yeah I remember that one
all right we've also got this one it
says thousands of tired nerve-shaking
over civilized people are beginning to
find out going to the mountains is going
home that Wilderness is a necessity
that's John Murr is that how you say it
Muir I gotta get out more Jade I think
that was shots fired from the team I
think it was they're telling us we need
to go on vacation and we need to go to
the mountains apparently but I like that
sometimes you do need to withdraw a
little bit some fresh air get a little
bit fresher
um and not to mention you know when it
comes to kind of doing good habits and
doing things for yourself
um let me talk about this it says so you
think you found your dream home but
before you sign those closing papers
make sure you steer clear of these
common first-time home buyer mistakes
navigating home buying with ease and
avoid the pitfalls when it comes to
buying your new home sweet home so this
is how you do that you need to Simply
sign up at ramsesolutions.com
newsletter and go ahead and subscribe to
our Sunday newsletter and learn how to
avoid making these common home buyer
mistakes guys subscribe to that every
every month there's new tips new things
to just make your life an amazing team
that's churning out super helpful
content yeah I'm like Google it bro we
got great stuff honestly sitting right
there on the ramseysolutions.com website
through the newsletter so check it out
yeah it's a lot of stuff it's really
great it'll make your life better it'll
help you it will help you learn all
right let's go to the phone lines again
Triple A
825-5225 we've got Jamie from St George
Utah we were just over in the Salt Lake
Area what's going on in your world Jamie
hi so glad to talk to you guys thank you
so much absolutely
my my question is
are
too big too late and the reason why I
say this is because I haven't been to
Washington listening to where everything
Ramsey for the last week and I went from
gazelle Focus totally excited to
Absolute fear because we have absolutely
nothing absolutely nothing we have eight
kids we've already failed the oldest
three although I hope to be able to
teach them these things too but we still
have six younger ones
um and I I like everything in me I I
haven't heard anybody with like our our
place and um I feel like I'm gonna fail
the budget I've never done one before in
my life I'm just kind of like um I'm a
stay-at-home mom and homeschooler so I'm
kind of like are we too old only too
late is this gonna happen how old are
you because you see energy of a 17 year
old
well thank you um I'm 40 I'll be 42. oh
my gosh
how are you still alive you're a newborn
baby you should run for president you're
so old
who told you you were old Jamie who told
you that it was too late for you she's
at home with these kids she is feeling
it right now that's what it is these
kids are running her ragged well because
I feel like I failed our older tree
already we can't help them pay for any
education whatsoever
hold on hold on hold on hold on I've
heard you say the word fail too many
times in this short period of time and I
want you to stop saying that okay nobody
talks to our friend Jamie like that yeah
especially not Jamie exactly stop using
that word fail because life we're
learning out here we're learning and
also there's like a 75 year old
listening right now who's offended that
you said you're old okay I know that's
right I'm sorry
let's roll this thing out because we the
the goal is for us to debunk everything
that you've just all the fears that
you've just laid out so let's look at
the finances here you got eight kids
what's the household income
income as I can while still being able
to be at home I mean daycare is way too
expensive for me to go out and get it
outside okay so how much is the debt
that you guys are facing
58 000
. what kind of debt is it give us the
breakdown
17-4 across seven credit cards we have a
7 800 car note five thousand medical and
my stupidity 27
000 in student loans
how much in student loans again sorry I
was writing all that down you know
twenty seven thousand twenty seven
thousand student loans all right I
thought you were gonna say a lot more
debt than what you said so I'm glad that
it's 58k because look here's the thing
it could be worse it could be a lot
worse your girl talking to you right now
I paid off 460 000 in the income at the
time when we started was 30 000. so when
I tell you all things are possible all
things are possible and it might require
you it probably is going to require you
to pick up some extra work whenever you
can find it and I'm not going to sit
over here and act like I know when that
is because you've got eight kids and
I've got two so whatever that looks like
for you and your husband there's you if
you want to get this done quickly you do
need to increase your income and you can
start thinking about ways that you could
do that but in the meantime you've been
listening to us for the past few weeks
we're going to tell you what we tell
everybody else to do you got to walk
through these baby steps thing one is
you gotta get that thousand dollars
saved I don't know if you've done that
yet but put aside a thousand dollars
most people can get it done in 30 days
if they're selling things going scorched
Earth and the kids let them know we're
eating noodles with butter this month
like that's what that's on the menu okay
and so that's what that looks like and
then we're gonna do we're gonna work
this debt through this debt snowball
we're gonna list them smallest to
largest not by interest rate balance
only smallest to largest so your
smallest balance looks like it's this
medical debt right the 5K uh or is it a
baby credit card
baby cry we have like a two 700 to 1700
so good you'll knock those out real fast
yeah it seems like that plus is
definitely possible you don't have any
money outside of the Thousand I feel
like you do
no we have nothing nothing at all
anything you can sell just two thousand
uh no we don't really have many quality
things I mean I could probably muster
out you know four or five low
cost things to sell but other than that
not really okay what's he doing for work
um he's a city he works for a city
locating utilities under the ground oh
okay yeah
um and I hope I mean I've I've been
looking for jobs like crazy and I'm
hoping to be able to at least add up to
20 000 a year yes from the jobs that
I've been able to find so I mean I'm no
stranger to work yeah that's incredible
I think if you can do that you've got to
do that and you know I take I've taken
this question a couple of times even on
my Instagram you know sometimes dealing
with single moms or people who are
really just at the brink and it's like
okay there does come a point where it's
like you're doing all that you can
you've taken all the extra jobs it
doesn't make sense to do this because of
daycare there does come a point where
it's like okay I'm bringing in what I
feel like is the amount of money and
then you just gotta ride it out man that
at some point it's like I've just gotta
ride the train until I get to the stop
and sometimes it is like that I do think
you can get your income up more
um but you might not you might not be
making 150k when this all shakes out you
might be at 80 or you might be at 90 but
keep going down that field and keep
pushing forward because you might you
might get your income up more than what
you ever thought possible but here's the
thing the time is going to pass so we've
got to keep going hard we've got to keep
being intense about this and it might
not go as fast as you want it to go you
guys have eight kids and that's a choice
that yeah you know that you yeah you've
got to deal with and so yeah it's about
finding ways to get that income up
getting the expenses down and just walk
through this snowball and at the end of
the day not taking on any more debt
drawing that Line in the Sand and saying
this is it I'm not borrowing any more
money my husband and I took us seven and
a half years Jamie to pay off our debt
so I this this might be a journey for
you but it's a journey worth going on
because at the end of the day like I
said the time is going to pass so go on
the journey and go on the ride and get
this debt paid off are you guys using a
budget
yeah
um I for the first time in my life I've
I did April which was the Lost Cause I
was just trying to look and see what
happened in April and find money and so
I'm working on the May one to get that
going is he on board with this this
feels like a Jamie plan so far
yeah it definitely started with me um
but I have been trying to
um tell him our why and he is definitely
getting on board more each day good well
I'm gonna make it easier for you we're
going to gift you Financial Peace
University for one year as well as every
dollar premium but I'll leave you with
this the best time to plant the tree was
30 years ago the second best time to
plan it is today you can do this
challenge oh thank you you got this
thank you thank you I actually really
love that quote George that was uh
it's not too late but we got to stop
looking to the past that's right into
the future and you're not a failure
you'll never get anywhere with that kind
of language and that's for any of y'all
listening be nicer to yourself and give
yourself some Grace out here all right
that does it for this hour be sure to
join us next time and remember when it
comes to your life and money you can
tell me that you won't do it but please
do not tell me that you can't
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay babies to go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]